des travaux de notre commission
d'enquête par l'audition de Monsieur
David de Simonet président directeur
général d'axantis que je remercie de
cette mobilisée en urgence pour cette
audition créée en 2007 le groupe acensis
est une entreprise de taille
intermédiaire composé de deux divisions
les colorants et la chimie fine et
compte près de 400 salariés c'est
l'activité de chimie film qui nous
intéresse plus particulièrement car
exercice produit des principes actifs
sur trois sites Pithiviers grâce et
Caleb au total l'activité pharmaceutique
représente près de la moitié de votre
chiffre d'affaires environ 90 millions
d'euros à son échelle votre groupe peut
donc participer à la défense de la
souveraineté industrielle française dans
le secteur stratégique de la santé il a
d'ailleurs bénéficié du soutien de
l'État au titre de l'aide à la
réindustrialisation à travers les
programmes d'investissement d'avenir
pour autant faute de repreneur le site
de Calec qui emploie 120 salariés a été
mis en liquidation judiciaire par le
tribunal de commerce d'Orléans la
semaine dernière outre sa dimension
sociale évidente cette situation pose
question pourquoi la pérennité du site
n'a-t-elle pas pu être assuré malgré le
soutien financier important que lui ont
apporté l'État et les collectivités
territoriales sur le site du groupe vous
mettez en avant le fait que je cite
depuis sa création le groupe amuni
stratégie d'innovation et
d'internationalisation il est ainsi
capable de mettre en oeuvre projet de
recherche et développement et de
production de molécules actives pour des
applications à forte valeur ajoutée pour
des marchés mondiaux
vous nous préciserez quels ont été les
productions mises sur le marché et les
partenariats que vous avez noués pour
mettre en œuvre ses orientations
stratégiques enfin pour revenir à
l'objet de notre commission d'enquête
voudrait bien nous indiquer comment
votre activité a pu être impactée par
les pénuries de matières premières et si
celle-ci ont joué un rôle dans la
décision de fermer le site de Calais
vous comprendrez qu'à l'heure où le
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre une
stratégie de souveraineté sanitaire la
fermeture d'un site de production de
principes actifs suscite des
interrogations nous serons également
attentifs aux précisions que vous nous
apporterez sur l'évolution des
livraisons à vos clients de l'industrie
pharmaceutique de principes actifs
fabriqués par votre groupe en clair
celle-ci a-t-elle eu un impact sur la
production de médicaments en aval
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets monsieur le
Président Directeur Général je vais vous
céder la parole pour un propos
introductif puis même Laurence Cohen
rapporteur de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera une série de questions comme
vous l'aurez compris notre commission
d'enquête en temps obtenir des réponses
étayées à des questions précises je
précise également que cette audition est
diffusée en direct sur le site internet
du Sénat il fera l'objet d'un
compte-rendu
publié avant de vous donner la parole je
vous rappelle qu'un faux témoignage
devant notre commission d'enquête est
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434 13 434 et 434 15 du code pénal je
vous invite à prêter serment de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité en
levant la main droite et en disant je le
jure je le jure
je vous remercie vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur vice-président
madame la rapporteur mesdames messieurs
je vous remercie de m'avoir convoqué à
cette commission d'enquête afin de
pouvoir partager une longue expérience
de la chimie fine notamment
pharmaceutique depuis plus de 25 ans
dont celle d'accentis groupe créé en
2007 cette expérience et vous l'avez dit
m'oblige à vous dire qu'elle est
contrastée entre d'une part la
conviction qui est la mienne depuis la
création du groupe qu'une réponse
industrielle aux pénurie de médicaments
et non seulement indispensable mais
encore sans doute possible et d'autre
part le constat que toutes les
conditions ne sont toujours pas réunies
pour préserver développer de façon
pérenne les outils industriels
nécessaires à une relocalisation qui ne
pourra être de toute façon que sélective
et stratégique des principes actifs
parmi les 8 unités de production
reprises par le groupe avec toujours la
volonté de rien industrialiser et de
redonner une de nouvelles activités
principalement orientée vers la vers la
pharmacie depuis la création des groupes
en 2007 j'ai dû me résoudre à mettre en
responsabilité de ses entités la société
syntaxime anciennement galère chimie qui
avait été reprise en 2013 et cette
décision que j'ai prise date de fin 2022
cette société vous l'avez rappelé en
l'absence de repreneur a été mise en
liquidation la semaine dernière avec une
poursuite d'activité d'un mois on
reviendra j'imagine au concept audition
sur cette élément d'actualité qui
préside sans nul doute à votre
convocation indépendamment de
l'expérience d'accentiste dans ce
contexte difficile je veux donc en guise
de propos liminaire partager des
éléments de diagnostic la faveur des
réussites et des échecs d'axantis et
formuler des propositions que j'avais
déjà eu l'occasion de formuler devant la
cabinet nationale de pharmacie lors
d'audience en 2011 et en 2013 Académie
qui s'était emparée de ces de ces sujets
de pénurie de médicaments de façon
synthétique l'évolution de la chimie n'a
pas échappé elle a tendance de fond à la
désindustrialisation notre pays depuis
30 ans la part de l'industrie dans le
pub a été divisé par deux et aujourd'hui
la part de l'industrie représente en
France la moitié
de ce qu'elle est en Allemagne il aura
fallu un choc comme celui de la covid
pour que tout le monde prenne conscience
des conséquences profondes de la
désindustrialisation moins d'industrie
signifie une perte de souveraineté quant
à l'accès à des produits essentiels par
exemple pour la santé les principes
actifs des médicaments sur qui est
l'activité cœur de Dax antis je
confirmer cette analyse dès 2014 dans
une article de la revue géopolitique
conflit le médicament l'arme blanche de
la géopolitique j'écrivais il s'agit
d'un enjeu géopolitique souhaitons-nous
aller
souhaitons-nous abandonner notre
indépendance dans la fabrication et donc
dans l'accès médical aux médicaments
notamment en cas de crise sanitaire bien
avant la crise covid nous avions en
effet des éléments de diagnostic déjà
disponibles le Sénat un logiciel
d'audition d'une commission d'enquête
sénatoriale sur le rôle des firmes
pharmaceutiques dans la gestion par
gouvernement de la grippe A H1 après
l'événement h1k le Sénat pointé déjà en
2010 je cite l'absence totale de
maîtrise des approvisionnements dans la
prévisibilité et la régularité
insuffisante aurait pu dans une autre
situation avoir des conséquences
sérieuses une prophétie une analyse qui
s'est confirmée pendant la crise covid
alors cette chaîne d'approvisionnement
dont vous recommandiez déjà une
meilleure maîtrise n'a cessé de
continuer à se fragmenter sous l'effet à
la fois de l'externalisation des phases
de production des principaux
laboratoires et la délocalisation de
cette production vers la zone Asie cette
fraction cette fragmentation portée
porte en elle la croissance des risques
du rupture plus il y a de maillon plus
la probabilité de défaut de l'ensemble
de la chaîne est forte cerise se mesure
également par l'apparition de coûts
cachés d'ailleurs une logique de
délocalisation uniquement motivée par la
recherche de gains sur les coûts en
réalité apparaissent des coûts cachés à
ceux qui en ont fait le choix et ont
accompagné cette délocalisation défauts
de fabrication liées à des défauts de
contrôle sur ces nouvelles zones de
production coup de transport élevé dont
le coût carbone délai de livraison et
arrêt de chaîne de production en aval
uneilatérale par les autorités comme en
Chine lorsque pour lutter contre la la
pollution atmosphérique les autorités
décident unilatéralement d'arrêter des
usines face à ces constats et à la
concurrence déloyale d'une partie des
producteurs en chinois en Inde après une
première séance en 2011 sous l'égide de
la cabinet nationale de pharmacie le
second séance était consacrée en mars
2013 aux médicaments rupture de stock
rupture d'approvisionnement une
problématique polymore diversité
d'origine solutions plurielle nous
recommandons alors à l'issue de ces de
ces séances de travail de reconstruire
une filière en Europe et faisions des
propositions encore d'actualité la
mention de l'origine du lieu de
fabrication des matières premières à
usage pharmaceutique des principes
actifs sur le conditionnement des
médicaments recommandations elle est
restée l'être morte la détermination
d'une liste de médicaments qui les
vitales de relocaliser en Europe pour
garantir l'indépendance de notre
politique de santé à l'occasion des
auditions que vous avez conduites la DGE
a confirmé aujourd'hui l'existence d'une
d'une liste de médicaments stratégiques
à un but
la dimension industrielle et sanitaire
on pourrait y ajouter comme proposition
de solutions face à un déficit de
compétitivité la prise en compte dans le
prix du médicament des contraintes
réglementaires légitimes j'ai aussi en
au visionnant les auditions de votre
commission réalisée que c'était une
demande quasi unanime étant
sous-traitant de l'industrie
pharmaceutique et notamment des
laboratoires il faut que cette prise en
compte dans le prix du médicament des
contraintes réglementaires des
producteurs soit partagé équitablement
entre les laboratoires et les
industriels en amont dont nous faisons
partie or si tout le monde comprend
désormais ces enjeux encore faillit-il
assuré dans un contexte de
désindustrialisation et de concurrence
des loyales depuis plus de 30 ans le
maintien des outils industriels afin de
bénéficier d'un mouvement de balancier
en faveur d'une relocalisation que
personne n'imaginait avant cette crise
covid mais ne soyons panaïfs si quelques
laboratoires responsables et quelques
écosystèmes régionaux ont permis à des
industriels d'assurer ce maintien en
conditions industrielles avant la crise
covid pour l'essentiel avant cette ce
sont les liens industriels eux-mêmes
dont accentis qui ont financé ce
maintien en conditions industrielles
c'est quoi un moment donné ne sont plus
supportables c'est le cas sur le site de
Calais vous y reviendrons à l'occasion
de vos questions et surtout la
relocalisation qui est sans doute une
réponse à ce déficit de souveraineté
quant à l'accès aux médicaments pour les
patients citoyens le
cette relocalisation elle ne sera que
limitée elle n'est pas encore engagée
massivement elle ne sera que sélective
sur les petites séries plus encore on
verra au mieux les effets positifs à
partir 2025 et 2026 je reviendrai sur
effectivement les programmes dont nous
avons bénéficié dans le cadre de France
relance mais compte tenu de l'inertie en
tout cas de la réalité de cette
industrie de sa dimension de recherche
d'industrialisation de réglementaire ça
prend plusieurs années
je voudrais juste d'ailleurs partager
avec vous une anecdote avant de créer ce
groupe je travaille dans un groupe
public la SNPE en 2005 face à la crise
H5 le ministère de la Santé nous avait
publicité pour fabriquer du tamifou
qu'elle ne fut pas ma surprise de
découvrir que la plupart des
interlocuteurs publics ont une
méconnaissance de la réalité de
l'inertie de la dimension industrielle
mettre en oeuvre une production de
tamifou prend des trois ou quatre ans et
n'est pas compatible avec la gestion
d'une crise c'est un autre élément sur
lequel j'espère j'aurai l'occasion
d'insister il y a une injonction
contradictoire à vouloir opérer de façon
compétitive des sites industriels en
France et en même temps d'avoir des
capacités disponibles pour faire face à
des risques de pandémie si on doit
garder la capacité disponible elle
représente un coup qui dans le domaine
de la défense est assumer par les
industriels de la défense dans le cadre
de maintien en conditions industrielles
c'est un vrai sujet que je voudrais
aborder si vous en êtes d'accord avec
vous et qui était au cœur du dilemme du
site du site de Calais car si la France
si France relance et législatives qui a
le tel que la manifestation atterrée
capacity ont marqué une inflexion depuis
2020 il reste d'autres contraintes à
lever en plus des recommandations sur le
marquage de l'origine des principes
actifs la prise en compte dans le prix
du médicament la dimension industrielle
de producteur principal actif je
voudrais citer les impôts de production
disproportionnées en France ainsi qu'une
surréglementation et un sur contrôle ou
des coûts énergétiques depuis 2021 qui
ont quadruplé s'agissant de nos
activités tout ceci nuit à la
compétitivité face à des concurrents qui
ne respectent pas les mêmes normes qui
nous sont imposées la question que mon
propos soit extrêmement clair les normes
sont source de progrès pour nos citoyens
et y compris pour les industriels que
nous sommes il n'est pas acceptable que
les importations de produits fabriqués
dans les zones qui ne respectent pas ces
normes
ne soient pas taxé ne soit pas davantage
contrôlé c'est ce que j'appelle la
dévaluation normative lorsque l'on
apporte des produits de d'industriels
qui ne respectent pas les normes
auxquelles nous sont contraintes c'est
une dévaluation normative comme on
parlait d'évaluation monétaire mettre en
oeuvre toutes ces solutions et lever les
contraintes supposent un temps long et
une cohérence entre les pouvoirs publics
entre eux et avec les grands donneurs
d'ordre dans la reconnaissance du
caractère stratégique de la dimension
industrielle du médicament qui lustre
l'activité des principes actifs merci
oui merci Monsieur pour vous propose
introductifs alors effectivement
d'ailleurs le président
Bruno Belin la souligné il y a quand
même une contradiction entre
le fait que vous
vous soyez à la fois un des quatre
principaux fabricants de principes
actifs en France si je ne me trompe pas
et qu'en même temps parallèlement et
bien vous
vous soyez amené à fermer une
usine à Calais
faute de repreneur alors pouvez-vous
vraiment nous expliquer les raisons qui
ont conduit à cette fermeture et par
conséquent parce que qui dit qui dit
fermeture dit quand même un coup porté à
quelque part à la souveraineté de la
France et à un coût aussi social
extrêmement important parce que ça
entraîne la suppression de 120 emplois
sur un site et vous l'avez souligné ou
l'activité chimique était très ancienne
et donc et qui constituait une capacité
de production qui était non négligeable
donc on est là dans un constat de
de pénurie de médicaments de rupture etc
et il y a une usine à Calais qui ferme
on a un peu l'impression par donnez moi
l'expression mais de marcher sur la tête
donc comment se fait-il que que on en
soit arrivé là et
qu'elles aident ou pas vous avez pu
obtenir au niveau de l'État parce que là
encore on est quand même dans une dans
une drôle de enfin de contradiction
c'est à dire que le gouvernement a juste
titre encourage à la relocalisation là
il y a eu toute une communication et
c'est tout à fait positif par rapport à
ces 15 c'est au fait qu'il va y avoir
une production donc de de
paracétamol etc donc vraiment voilà
l'usine va sortir de terre on a eu
l'occasion avec la présidente qui est
excusée aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais nous avons eu l'occasion de visiter
le site et donc est-ce que le
gouvernement vous a apporté une aide une
aide quelconque ça je pense que c'est la
première chose que je voudrais vous vous
demandez et du coup vous demandez aussi
faire le lien et après je vous poserai
d'autres questions mais peut-être qu'on
reste quand même sur ce cette usine à
Calais vous avez bâti une ti à peu près
en une décennie cette ETI emploi si mais
enseignements sont exacts à peu près 450
salariés qui sont répartis dans
plusieurs
usines donc on a on a cité donc Calais
Pithiviers grâce mais là avec 120
emplois de moins au lieu d'avoir 450 bah
c'est 450 - 120 et et donc c'est là
encore il va y avoir une chute des
salariés donc une productivité beaucoup
moins beaucoup moins importante
et en même temps
vous l'avez un peu souligné en creux si
je puis dire à partir du moment où vous
produisez des principes actifs en France
alors que nous savons que 80% des
principes actifs sont produits en Chine
où en Inde
j'imagine que vous avez des exigences en
termes de respect
environnementaux et respect sociaux qui
sont peut-être plus importants que ce
qui peut se trouver par ailleurs
délocaliser dans d'autres parties du
monde mais là encore je
comment je suis prudente parce que à
partir du moment où une usine est fermée
et que ça entraîne des licenciements
c'est un peu difficile de parler de
respect
des des critères sociaux donc je vais je
vais me cantonner sur ces deux questions
qui ce qu'ils font bloc en fait et puis
ensuite je vous poserai des questions on
va dire plus plus globales sur votre
activité en
termes plus précis de de du rôle que
vous pouvez jouer au niveau de
l'industrie chimique
merci Madame pour toi pour ces questions
donc le site de Calais est un site qui a
été repris en 2013 ce site s'appelait
alors Kader chibi galère chimie avait
été jusqu'à fin 2012 la propriété du
groupe Tessenderlo dont d'ailleurs
l'État français était actionnaire cette
usine qui a l'air chimie avait été en
situation de très large très important
sous-activité après avoir perdu un
intermédiaire pharmaceutique avec le
groupe GSK face à cette sous-activité le
groupe Tessenderlo a céder cette usine à
un fond luxembourgeois fin 2012
6 mois après se font
ni redressement judiciaire et c'est s'en
est suivi le liquidation de cette usine
sur Calais en six mois
l'industriel qui reprend une usine s'il
a un projet pour le déployer il faut
plusieurs années
dans ce contexte difficile dans un dans
un environnement dans un contexte
industriel en 2013 très différent de
celui dans lequel nous sommes
aujourd'hui et je reviendrai sur
l'aspect social qui aujourd'hui ma
priorité sur la gestion des conséquences
de la décision du tribunal lorsqu'on
reprend lorsqu'on
bâtit un projet pour reprendre cette
usine nous sommes les seuls à déposer à
l'époque une offre il y a deux cent
salariés je me suis entretenu à quelques
centaines de mètres d'ici avec la
sénatrice
maire de Calais sur cette situation
puisqu'on voyait dans excentis déjà
présent à Calais la seule solution en
réalité pour sauver une partie des 200
emplois nous avons de monter ce projet
bien que l'usine
perdait alors près 10 millions d'euros
par an bien que cette usine présente une
sous-activité très forte
et bien que nous n'ayons pas pu visiter
l'usine qui avait été bloqué
j'ai envie de façon quasi légitime
compte tenu des conditions dans
lesquelles tessenderlow avait vendu
cette usine se font peu scrupuleux nous
avons déployé une stratégie sur
plusieurs années d'abord l'objectif
était effectivement de redonner une
vocation pharmaceutique à cette usine
l'activité pharmaceutique représentait
une minorité
force est de constater
c'est une usine qui a des importants
volumes force est de constater qu'il n'y
a pas aujourd'hui de place pour de la
relocalisation pour développement de
molécules à très fort volumes la
compétitivité sur les molécules très
fort volume est encore beaucoup plus
dégradé par rapport à aux zones nazis
c'est pour ça que l'enseignement que
j'en tire c'est que la relocalisation ne
peut se faire que sur des petites séries
des molécules à très forte valeur
ajoutée donc c'est un échec
je vous en prie madame
est-ce que vous nous pourriez donner un
exemple de molécules très fort volume
c'est ce qu'on appelle des blockbusters
des génériques des principes actifs ou
parler de paracétamol tout à l'heure
sont des molécules à très fort volume
dont le prix de vente va atteindre
quelques dizaines d'euros du kilos là où
sur de la chimie fine pour des principes
pour des médicaments innovants on est
sur des niveaux de prix qui permettent
de justifier à différentiel de
compétitivité plus défavorable donc il y
avait des capacités importantes
disponibles une force aux activités
une fois qu'on reprend cette usine on
est déjà présent industriellement par
une petite usine à Calais et donc on
gère le transfert de la petite usine
vers Keller qui était en sous-activité
de façon à absorber une partie de ces
activités nous avons eu à gérer
quelques années après les impacts de la
crise des migrants sur Calais
ce site reposait sur un fret ferroviaire
Fred ferroviaire qui n'était plus
accessible on a dû changer la logistique
de cette usine quelques années après
cette usine de chimie disposée d'un
incinérateur pour traiter une partie des
rejets de l'usine et faisait de la
prestation pour le compte de tiers un
concurrent belge c'est implanté à
Dunkerque avec un incinérateur deux fois
plus important en capacité avec les
mêmes moyens qui ce qui a tué
économiquement c'est incinérateur sans
incinérateur la gestion l'usine a été
rendue encore plus compliquée bref
un point de départ complexe c'est la
solution en difficulté que nous avons
acheté dans l'histoire du groupe
l'objectif était clair d'y développer de
la pharmacie de l'activité
pharmaceutique à fort volume nous n'y
sommes pas arrivés
j'en tiens la conclusion encore une fois
que le marché la possibilité de
relativiser des très forts volumes à
faire valeur ajoutée me paraît
relativement innusoire et puis des aléas
des événements extérieurs qui n'ont rien
à voir avec ce dont on parle aujourd'hui
mais comme industriel on évolue dans des
écosystèmes
la crise des migrants c'est une réalité
et d'ailleurs vous parliez
d'intervention de des collectivités
locales c'est à ce moment là que après
avoir fait constater les difficultés
inhérentes à cette situation là nous
avons bénéficié d'un financement de la
région de 0,8 millions et d'une aide à
la réindustrialisation d'un million
d'euros
de du ministre de l'économie
pour accompagner ce projet
crise émigrants situation logistique
arrêt de l'incinérateur
nous avons commencé à transférer
quelques productions des eaux d'usines
du groupe
qui elle était plutôt saturée et donc
dès qu'on avait des activités
complémentaires au lieu d'investir dans
les autres usines que vous avez cité à
Pithiviers ou agrace orgafarm ou centifa
nous transférions les productions sur
Calais
malheureusement la sous-activité a
perduré
nous n'avons comblé qu'une petite partie
finalement de la sous-activité et donc
les pertes se sont accumulées le groupe
a financé en moyen humain en
investissement à partir de novembre 2013
jusqu'à novembre
2022 plus de 26 millions d'euros
que nous avons décidé d'abandonner donc
le premier créancier de cette entité
c'est le groupe
c'est 26 millions d'euros pourquoi avoir
accepté de supporter autant de pertes
aussi longtemps
pour la problématique qui nous occupe
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que on a
financé un maintien en conditions
industrielles
en anticipant des croissances fortes
d'activité pharmaceutiques encore une
fois les caractéristiques de l'usine ces
forts volumes la faible compétitivité
non pas permis d'accrocher ses volumes
pour autant nous avions dans notre
portefeuille R&D de projets en phase
clinique
qui était en phase 3 pour deux
laboratoires français et malheureusement
en 2022 successivement ces deux
laboratoires ont annoncé des résultats
cliniques
défavorables qui ont conduit ces deux
laboratoires pharmaceutiques à arrêter
ces projets
sur ces deux projets nous anticipions
effectivement de les industrialiser sur
le site de Calais donc des pertes
cumulées au niveau que je vous ai
indiqué des caractéristiques de l'usine
par ces forts volumes et ça fait
compétitivité qui ne permettait pas de
prendre du volume significatif et
l'arrêt de ces deux projets par ces deux
sociétés pharmaceutiques sur des phases
3 en raison de ces clinique insuffisants
m'ont mis dans une situation
face à laquelle j'avais pu le choix pour
à la fois protéger une entreprise et lui
permettre de de provoquer l'intérêt d'un
repreneur et en même temps de protéger
le groupe que de mettre l'entreprise
redressement judiciaire finalement
malheureusement malgré les actions de
l'administrateur malgré les actions que
j'ai pu mener il y a eu de nombreuses
visites de l'usines il n'y a pas eu de
repreneur qui a confirmé une offre
je ne peux que le regretter
s'agissant du groupe accentis c'est ce
que je disais en introduction
aujourd'hui
cette décision est à la fois
paradoxale avec mes propositions
publiques qui remontent maintenant à
plus de 10 ans sur ce besoin de de
capacité pour assurer la souveraineté
c'est un échec
il faut en tirer des conséquences
des événements extérieurs qui n'ont rien
à voir finalement avec les éléments de
marché à part les deux arrêts de de
projets des deux groupes pharmaceutiques
des deux sociétés pharmaceutiques
aujourd'hui la priorité ce sont
effectivement c'est effectivement
l'aspect social et la spécialité ce sont
les deux questions que vous m'avez
posées
en plus de celle me demandant de
rappeler les causes en fait de qui nous
ont conduits à cette situation sur le
volet sanitaire aujourd'hui on est en
lien avec la NSM il y a un principe
actif de l'usine qui met en tension un
de nos clients
le tissulfiram
pour autant le marché n'est pas lui en
tension il n'y a pas de risque de
pénurie du médicament quant à l'accès
aux patients il y a un risque pour le
client qui nous achète ce produit de ne
plus disposer lui de stock mais c'est un
produit générique il y a des
alternatives il y a pas d'eau risque
sanitaires identifiés et c'est le
corollaire de ce que je vous disais
l'activité de ce site malheureusement
sur sa partie principale actif
pharmaceutique ne représente pas plus de
25% du chiffre d'affaires
sur l'aspect social plus d'une centaine
de CDI vous l'avez rappelé
aujourd'hui
il est important d'accompagner
de la meilleure des façons il y a une
négociation la semaine dernière
parallèlement à l'audience du tribunal
de commerce de façon à trouver un point
d'équilibre dans ce contexte difficile
je sais pas d'ailleurs le terme de point
d'équilibre n'est pas heureux mais de
trouver au moins un accord avec la
représentants des salariés pour pouvoir
assurer la production et la mise en
sécurité de l'usine avant son arrêt
définitif l'autre volet et le groupe il
contribue
par des moyens supplémentaires engagés
dans l'usine l'autre élément extrêmement
important c'est l'aspect donc social et
reclassement nous avons sur les autres
villes du groupe plus de 30 postes à
pourvoir qui sont communiqués aux
salariés il y aura des mesures
d'accompagnement des mesures de mobilité
indispensables dans cette situation là
nous sommes pas dans le même contexte
que celui de 2013 quand j'ai repris
cette usine il y a aujourd'hui et pour
échanger avec à la fois des clients à la
fois des concurrents
collègues partenaires des postes
aujourd'hui à pouvoir dans cette
industrie puisqu'effectivement les
usinités qui sont à majorité format dont
les deux autres unités de chimie film du
groupe elles sont bien dans cette
tendance que dont vous prenez la mesure
au fur et à mesure des auditions dans
cette tendance à une relocalisation même
si je dis qu'elle est sélective qu'elle
n'est pas massive mais elle existe et
donc c'est suppléments d'activité
permettent
pour y répondre aujourd'hui il y a
besoin de salariés qualifiés or les
salariés de Calais sont qualifiés il y a
pas doute là-dessus ils sont
professionnels ils connaissent les
enjeux qualité et sécurité sécurité
puisque nous sommes sur des sites
cesveso et donc encore une fois la
priorité du groupe aujourd'hui
c'est de pouvoir accompagner par ses
postes de reclassement et de par les
réseaux le réseau auquel on appartient
de tous ces industriels qui aujourd'hui
travaillent plus en partenariat que par
le passé
de trouver des solutions rapidement pour
les salariés de Calais
merci
je continue sur cette sur cette logique
par rapport à ces principes actifs parce
que en 2021 vous avez engagé un
programme de recherche pour relocaliser
des principes actifs de médicaments
utilisent notamment en réanimation et en
anesthésie et on sait que la demande a
explosé depuis le début de la crise je
pense à l'adrénaline proposol ou encore
Fontanil et si j'en crois les
informations qui sont parues dans la
presse
l'investissement correspondant est élevé
à 6 millions d'euros qui a été
co-financé par l'État 60% et vous avez
été lauréat de l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt capacity building pour lui
principes actifs donc là encore je
trouve qu'il y a un paradoxe dans cette
dynamique de fermer un site de de
production franchement je ne vois pas
je ne vois pas le lien et alors
peut-être que je serai mieux éclairé
si nous avions peut-être vous pouvez pas
nous le donner aujourd'hui mais auquel
cas vous pourrez nous le faire parvenir
par écrit mais en fait cette usine de
Calais
quelle part elle prenait parce que vous
nous venez de dire que ça constitue 25%
du chiffre d'affaires bon donc mais en
fait de quel principe actif il s'agit
pour pour quelle qu'elle part etc etc
parce que si vous voulez on comprit
notre notre commission d'enquête c'est à
la fois un état des lieux vous avez vu
puisque vous avez vu les les bandes
c'est un état des lieux mais en même
temps on souhaite faire des
recommandations pour justement
dépasser ce ce problème de de pénurie de
rupture etc phénomène qui n'est pas
nouveau qui redondant mais qu'il a
touche de plus en plus de molécules donc
c'est vrai que votre
enfin disons ce que la situation que que
vous vivez dans votre groupe au niveau
de Calais et vraiment un paradoxe donc
ça j'aimerais que vous puissiez sur
cette sur cette ces questionnements que
je me pose et
vous avez vous l'avez dit donc il y a
quand même donc 60% co-financer par
l'État il y a eu un moment donné aide de
la région et également une aide du
ministre du ministère de l'Économie donc
un certain nombre d'aides donc à partir
du ou du moment où vous allez fermer
Calais est-ce que il y a un plan de
remboursement de ces aides publiques
bien
plusieurs usines de production plusieurs
filiales plusieurs réalités économiques
et industrielles vous avez des sites qui
ont été repris à la création du groupe
en 2007
kalerchimie repris en 2013 une usine qui
appartenait au groupe 3M au groupe
américain au prix en 2016
unité reprise en 2013 de chromatographie
qui appartenait autrefois à Sanofi bref
je l'ai rappelé en introduction 8 unités
de production ont été reprises et ont
constitué accentis
bien avant les constats que vous faites
aujourd'hui
et c'était dans l'ADN du groupe nous
avons repris dans un contexte de
désindustrialisation qui n'est pas celui
d'aujourd'hui où on prend conscience
uniquement avec la crise covid de
l'importance de ces industries le
constat de du besoin de ces industries
je l'avais fait il a été conforté par
des échanges je les rappelais tout à
l'heure dans le cadre de la cabinatiale
de pharmacie vous-même vous aviez déjà
identifié il y a plus de 10 ans le
besoin de ses capacités industrielles
mais enfin qui
depuis plus de 10 ans à maintenu des
capacités industrielles quel est un
échec j'en ai rappelé les les causes en
partie des événements extérieurs le
point de départ aussi plus compliqué
c'est la seule usine reprise dans
l'histoire du groupe qui était en grande
difficulté déjà à l'origine il y a 10
ans mais encore une fois c'est
reprise de capacités industrielles si
nous les avions pas faites
si nous les avions pas faites issus nous
n'avions pas réussi quant aux autres à
les repositionner aujourd'hui il n'y
aurait plus ses capacités industrielles
donc je cherche pas à contrebalancer si
vous voulez l'échec qu'il en est un que
j'assume comme dirigeant c'est mon rôle
d'assumer ce choix même si je le referai
sans doute avec son des depuis 10 ans
des des choses à corriger à la marge
mais c'est la réalité de cette usine de
ces forts volumes de production qui la
destine plutôt à prendre des des
molécules lactives à volume importante
dans des conditions économiques qui ne
sont pas viables par rapport à cette
concurrence asiatique vous parliez de
France relance et de l'appel à mission
d'intérêt de capacity et bien ça vient
justement illustrer ce que je suis en
train de dire nous avons répondu pour
huit molécules dont l'adrénaline à
noradrénaline que vous devenez citer ce
sont des toutes petites fabrications on
parle de l'échelle de quelques kg
seul l'usine de Pithiviers avec ses
capacités de recherche 2 kg de pilotes
et des selles industrielles qui est la
combinaison d'une usine reprise en 2007
et de deux et en 2016 de mon voisin 3M
qui si nous l'avions pas repris auraient
fermé c'est la combinaison de ces deux
usines qui permet de prendre en main ces
sujets donc quand je parle de
relocalisation sélective la
relocalisation elle ne s'offera que sur
des petites séries pour des produits à
forte valeur ajoutée dont l'adrénaline
on la noradrénaline ces produits ne
pouvaient pas malheureusement remplir
les capacités industrielles de Calais
je suis un industriel si nous avions eu
la possibilité de trouver les produits
pour réouvrir les deux ateliers en fait
qui sont à l'arrêt depuis plus de 10 ans
qui était à l'arrêt avant qu'on reprenne
cette usine je l'aurais fait
rien ne dit et tout le contraire dont
mon histoire personnelle et dans ce des
collaborateurs du Groupe
que les reprises de capacité bien avant
la prise de conscience collective dont
vous faites l'écho
bien avant cette prise de conscience
nous on a été à la manoeuvre pour
préserver ses capacités industrielles
donc nous avons remporté effectivement
la mi capacity Lamy capacity c'est de la
Recherche et Développement pour mettre
au point des procédés de synthèse de
l'adrénaline de la Nora dans Lénine
notamment les 8 principes actifs sur
lesquels nous sommes positionnés sont
effectivement les principes actifs pour
l'anesthésie pour la ou pour la
réanimation ils sont aujourd'hui gérés
par les capacités de pitiver qui sont
des capacités très différentes de celle
de Calais dans notre métier de
fabrication principale actif il y a des
petites séries et des très grandes
séries et d'ailleurs les premières
molécules qui ont été délocalisées sont
évidemment les molécules à très grande
série
et donc
et donc cette apparente contradiction
elle révèle en fait qui a de l'avenir
pour un certain type de capacités et
qu'en revanche la relocalisation est une
illusion absolue sur un certain type de
molécules dont les volumes sont
importants et pour lesquels la
compétitivité est insuffisante
maintenant s'agissant des
aides la mi capacity ce sont des prêts
qu'il reste à rembourser sur orga farm
et
les bilans sont fait régulièrement
heureusement avec la DGE avec la BPI qui
viennent audité vérifier l'avancement de
ces projets mais qui prennent du temps
j'ai vu lors d'une audition
effectivement
la présentation du projet que sur la
relocalisation du paracétamol vous avez
visité l'installation il y a une inertie
extraordinairement forte qu'entre le
moment où prenez la décision de de
développer en R&D une molécule et où
vous allez l'industrialiser c'est un une
durée de 3 à 5 ans
donc encore une fois qu'elle est un
échec
la priorité aujourd'hui c'est l'impact
sanitaire et social sur la taxe
sanitaire je me suis sans doute mal
exprimé ce que je disais c'est que moins
de 25% du chiffre d'affaires de l'usine
de Calais se destinent industrie
pharmaceutique et donc c'est ça la
difficulté c'est que finalement cette
une usine qui aujourd'hui ne répond pas
aux besoins du marché pharmaceutique tel
qu'il existe en Europe et malgré cette
amorce de relocalisation
dont je redis qu'elle ne sera que
sélective et sur les petites séries
le paracétamol est un contre-exemple
oui c'est c'est un contre-exemple c'est
un contre-exemple mais c'est une
exception
juste une dernière explication comme
vous dites que nous n'avons pas pu
utiliser les capacités
oui les capacités de caler pourquoi
parce que c'est des machines trop
vieilles qui correspondent
les pièces pour faire le montage alors
comprimé
enfin je sais pas moi
ça c'est effectivement l'activité de
formulation qui est juste après la nôtre
on fait des principes actifs et en fait
vous avez des volumes de de qui sont
liés au volume des médicaments dont
l'industrie a besoin vous avez des
volumes de synthèse qui sont plus ou
moins importants dit trivialement vous
pouvez faire de la synthèse à l'échelle
du laboratoire qui sont des paillasses
de lycée jusqu'au kilo là puis à
l'échelle pilote puis à l'échelle
industrielle l'échelle industrielle pour
être rentré dans le concret on a des
réacteurs de 3-4 mètres cubes sur notre
usine de Pithiviers qui permettent de
faire des séries courtes sur Calais il y
a des réacteurs 3 4 mètres cubes mais la
une activité elle est sur des volumes
assez importants de plusieurs dizaines
de mètres cubes cumulées sur ces
ateliers
et c'est pas faute de les avoir fait
visiter revisiter par des donneurs
d'ordre des clients
internationaux et le constat était le
même l'outil en tant que tel à une
valeur si vous voulez technique mais la
compétitivité du site et les
caractéristiques industrielles de ce
site
c'est à dire des volumes importants
disponibles ne répondent pas aujourd'hui
au
aux demandes de l'industrie
pharmaceutique sachant que la
relocalisation encore une fois elle est
plutôt sur des petites séries et pour
être encore plus concret je vous parlais
tout à l'heure de la lamotrigine qui est
le produit et l'intermédiaire de la mode
tragique qui était fait autrefois pour
GSK par cette usine c'était quasiment la
moitié du chiffre d'affaires de l'usine
c'est l'arrêt de cette production
lorsque tcno a perdu le contrat qui a
entraîné cette sous-activité et une
liquidation en 2013 avant qu'on ne
reprenne l'usine je n'ai eu de cesse
avec les équipes commerciales avec
l'appui des salariés de l'usine
et je comprends aujourd'hui c'est plus
qu'a paradoxe c'est un déchirement et
c'est une difficulté et je suis pas
devenu industriel pour gérer ce type de
situation
pour autant
aujourd'hui
des produits comme la lamotrigine
l'intermédiaire dans ces fameuses
ateliers qui sont vides depuis plus de
15 ans et bien nous n'en n'avons pas
trouvé
et l'usine aujourd'hui a été visitée
dans le cadre de judiciaire là encore
par des concurrents par des clients je
crains que le même constat ait été fait
donc l'enseignement que j'en tire c'est
qu'effectivement l'art localisation qui
est une réponse à la pénurie de
médicaments elle ne peut être que encore
une fois sélective et sur des capacités
qui démontrent une un minimum de
compétitivité
oui c'est un contre-exemple
il m'appartient pas de commenter ce
contre-exemple
c'est un contre-exemple c'est une
exception
il y a une valeur symbolique
extraordinairement forte indépendamment
de la dimension sanitaire
à saisir au niveau de notre commission
notre commission d'enquête parce que
vous dites que le paracétamol c'est un
contre-exemple on a été aussi visité
rohapi
euroapy il travaille 24 heures sur 24
au niveau des des équipes etc c'est tout
c'est pas du tout le paracétamol
et donc moi j'arrive pas à comprendre en
fait quel est votre votre modèle c'est à
dire
j'ai bien compris que
l'usine de Calais n'était pas seulement
dédiée à l'industrie pharmaceutique donc
effectivement mais quand vous reprenez
cette usine en 2013 et que visiblement
votre comment dirais-je votre votre
activité principale votre objectif etc
c'est quand même l'industrie chimique
pharmaceutique je n'arrive pas à
comprendre le décalage qu'il y a c'est à
dire à ce moment-là et maintenant on est
on est en 2023 j'ai compris les déboires
etc qui sont extérieurs et qui
effectivement peuvent expliquer ça je
veux bien comprendre mais c'est pas ça
c'est finalement de quel quel est le
modèle économique que vous avez
que vous avez utilisé pour essayer de
relancer tout ou une partie de cette
usine parce que
enfin ça y est calé et fermé et on va
aller essayer de chercher à relocaliser
ailleurs ou etc des productions on va
pleurer sur le manque de production de
principes actifs en disant oh là là
c'est terrible 80% en Chine en Asie donc
si vous voulez je suis désolé j'insiste
j'insiste mais c'est pour pour bien
comprendre
qu'est-ce qui précisément n'a pas
fonctionné et en même temps
vous avez des aides
qui sont pas
extraordinaires mais vous avez quand
même des aides qui sont des aides du
Ministère de la Région
vous êtes reconnu par rapport à huit de
vos principes actifs
il y a un truc qui est un truc qui
cloche quoi non enfin je pardon mais je
comprends je m'interrogerais de la même
façon et de toute façon j'ai parlé de
dilemmes tout à l'heure évidemment
sur les décisions qu'on prend pas la
légère
ce sont des questions que je me suis
posé maintes et maintes fois
s'agissant de de
Calais encore une fois une activité
pharmaceutique limitée une activité
pharmaceutique
le bilan que vous faites aujourd'hui et
toutes les auditions que vous avez
conduite
parle du nouveau monde si j'ose dire ce
nouvel environnement de 2020
où on parlerait de relocalisation
où on dirait finalement aujourd'hui il y
a de l'eau il y a de la demande pour ce
type d'industrie
les unités qui ont
bénéficié du plan de relocalisation ou
de plan de relance encore une fois
centré sur hangapharm c'est pas
syntaxime un caractéristique permettait
pas de se positionner d'ailleurs sur ces
projets France relance donc à faire mon
a bénéficié deux entités disjointe mais
cette prise de conscience très récente
à la fois des donneurs d'ordre
d'ailleurs parce que avant la crise
covid et dans l'ordre commencer à voir
ces fameux coups cachés de cette
externalisation et délocalisation
massive que j'ai appelé en propos
liminaire mais depuis quand les
acheteurs des grands donneurs d'ordre ou
des laboratoires depuis quand l'État se
soucie réellement du maintien de ces
conditions industrielles
depuis la crise covid non pas parce que
le diagnostic est nouveau mais c'est
parce que ce diagnostic finalement il
n'avait pas été rendu public le patient
citoyen depuis plus de 30 ans n'avait
pas conscience du fait que il l'avait
perdu accès au traitement et aux
solutions thérapeutiques c'est cette
filament prise de conscience du patient
citoyen qui exerce une pression sur le
politique
l'élaboratoires eux ils voient
aujourd'hui une solution durable face à
des coûts cachés qui n'imaginait pas
quand ils avaient commencé à délocaliser
et on va je parlais tout à l'heure de la
délocalisation on n'avait occulté le
coup carbone donc cette prise de
conscience elle est extrêmement récente
mais moi si vous voulez tout ce constat
là
et je le faisais il y a déjà plus de 10
ans il est exactement à l'origine de
cette motivation que j'avais à reprendre
calée en 2013 simplement entre 2013 et
2020 21 avant que cette prise de
conscience de s'opère chez les grands
donneurs d'ordre et au niveau de l'État
pendant 8 ou 9 ans qui finance la
sous-activité de l'usine qui essaie
malgré tout de trouver des solutions les
salariés de l'usine les salariés du
groupe
nous avons échoué parce que le contexte
n'était pas favorable il est davantage
aujourd'hui mais le point de départ
c'est une perte de 26 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui c'est un profil d'activité
insuffisamment pharmaceutique
il aurait fallu quelqu'un d'autre prenne
le relais nous sommes allés au bout de
cette logique donc la contradiction vous
avez raison elle est entre l'entité et
les tendances et ce qui sait depuis deux
trois ans qui sont confirmés mais quand
on on
analyse en détail cette tendance là vous
avez la prise de conscience en 2020 vous
avez le plan de France relance avec la
limite capacity en 2021 puis les
lauréats vont faire de la R&D pendant
deux trois ans puis ils vont
industrialiser on se retrouve avec des
activités pendant 2025 et 2026 et désolé
nous n'avions plus les moyens de de
financer les pertes et ce que j'ai
appelé le maintien en condition
industrielle de cette usine
et il y a pas de il y a pas de sujet si
vous voulez tabou
j'ai peut-être vous surprendre en vous
disant que oui
cette industrie aurait mérité
qui est une approche sans doute un peu
différente
comme groupe indépendant nous avons
financé le maintien en conditions
industrielles
de façon majoritaire 26 millions d'euros
aujourd'hui dans il se trouve que dans
l'activité précédente j'étais dans un
groupe qui était dans la chimie civile
et militaire le maintien en condition
industrielle ça existe
un ancien ministre de l'Économie disait
d'ailleurs s'agissant des médicaments
l'enjeu est au moins aussi important que
dans l'accès à l'énergie ou dans l'accès
à l'indépendance
sur la dimension militaire
mais finalement si vous voulez je
pensais au cœur vous parlez de
contradiction
on découvre que le médicament en fait
c'est pas un produit comme les autres
mais on l'a libéré aux forces de la
mondialisation et la financiarisation
c'est ça la réalité
et donc je parlais tout à l'heure du
marquage
pourquoi il n'y a pas de marquage sur
les boîtes de médicaments de l'origine
du lieu de fabrication
vous savez quand j'ai plaidé cette
solution il y a plus dix ans les
pharmaciens m'ont dit mais vous n'y sont
pas vous allez accroître les pénuries
parce que pensez-vous que le patient
citoyen qui a désormais accès de façon
transparente au lieu de fabrication du
principe actif 9 faces forcément ils
préfèrera sans doute un lieu de
production dont il identifie les enjeux
et qui évolue dans un environnement
géopolitique sur lesquels il a un
contrôle par son droit de vote donc tous
ces sujets là sont extraordinairement
complexes
il y a une contradiction apparente par
rapport à l'environnement dans lequel on
est mais moi comme acteur privé je suis
allé au bout de ce que l'on pouvait
faire et ça m'a été reproché
donc c'est un échec je l'assume j'en
tire les conséquences que lorsqu'on
prend une entreprise en difficulté et
qu'on a des événements extérieurs qui
surgissent c'est encore plus compliqué
on a pourtant pas baissé les bras les
salariés de l'usine et les salariés du
groupe pendant 10 ans et oui c'est une
contradiction par rapport à ce qui est
en train de se passer donc j'aurais aimé
qu'un repreneur se positionne des
concurrences sont venus à tes clients
sont venus se positionnent européen
asiatique
j'aurais aimé que un industriel se
positionne maintenant nous en sommes là
j'assume ma part de responsabilité je
vous expliquais l'origine de la décision
2013 du cheminement jusqu'à aujourd'hui
il y a cette dimension sociale et si
nous pouvons recruter plus d'une
trentaine de collaborateurs de Calais et
évidemment on a déjà communiqué les
postes et on donnera des mesures
d'accompagnement la mobilité c'est très
important aussi dans la la défense de
l'industrie
mais l'accompagnement de la mobilité des
salariés c'est parce que les autres
usines ne vivent pas du tout la même
situation à l'origine sont les
usines majoritairement pharmaceutiques
et ce sont des usines qui ont des moyens
de R&D de petites fabrication qui
correspondent mieux aux projets
sur lesquels on a dû travailler
notamment dans ce contexte de
relocalisation dont les molécules de la
manifestation d'intérêt capacity
mais c'est une contradiction violente
et je vous assure qu'il voilà me fait
réfléchir tous les jours au sens de
cette industrie et et à mes propres
responsabilités
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
finalement
les deux usines de Pithiviers de Grasse
qu'elle production elles ont en termes
de principes actifs alors on a
aujourd'hui plus d'une trentaine de
principes actifs qui se répartissent
entre une moitié de principes actifs
génériques et une moitié de principes
actif pour des médicaments innovants
sachant que sur les principes actifs
innovants la particularité c'est que
nous fabriquons des principes actifs
pour des médicaments qui sont distribués
pour lesquels le client dispose déjà
d'une autorisation de mise sur le marché
d'une AMM et on fabrique aussi des lots
pour des médicaments qui sont en phase
de recherche ça c'est extrêmement
important
sur l'usine de Pithiviers nous pouvons
rentrer quasiment délifaces
pré-cliniques dans la gestion du projet
du principe actif pour le médicament du
de nos clients donc on a une majorité
d'activités qui est sur l'industrie
pharmaceutique
essentiellement des principes actifs
pour moitié des principes actifs
génériques dont nous possédons les
dossiers les certificats de conformité à
la Pharmacopée Européenne et les deux
dans le master find auquel les clients
se réfèrent et qui finalement nous
permet de tisser le lien avec eux et
puis les principes actifs innovants
soient des médicaments qui viennent
d'être lancés sur le marché pour
lesquels
dont nos clients possèdent évidemment le
brevet la propriété intellectuelle et
puis des produits pour les phases
cliniques alors ça c'est très important
d'ailleurs si ils permettent un
commentaire sur la relocalisation je
disais c'est une illusion elle sera que
sélective ce qui est important c'est
moins la religion physique c'est-à-dire
que les tonnes qui sont partis en Asie
ne Rev iendront pas il faudrait
construire dix fois plus d'usines en
Europe pour rapatrier tout ce qui a été
délocalisé l'acceptabilité sociétale
d'usine de chimie sesves
elle est faible
très faible et ça alors vous parliez de
contradiction je veux bien assumer les
miennes mais il y a des injonctions
contradictoires lors d'une des auditions
j'ai été assidue cette nuit lors du des
auditions que j'ai que j'ai écoutées à
des intervenants rappelés que finalement
on était sur de multiples titles
nous sommes sur la tutelle de Bercy en
cette logique de relocalisation nous
sommes sous la tutelle du ministère de
la Santé de la NSM puisque nous mettons
en oeuvre des fabrications principes
actifs mais nous sommes aussi sur la
tutelle que nous sommes une usine nous
avons des unes ces vaisseaux sous la
tutelle du ministère de l'Environnement
d'avoir pris cette décision et de d'oser
rappeler dans votre commission
l'importance de l'industrie ce sont des
salariés qui ont général des niveaux de
rémunération qui sont 40 à 50% supérieur
à la moyenne constaté dans les bassins
d'emploi par les données de l'INSEE
1 euro investi dans nos usines génèrent
de leur point direct donc la question
d'ailleurs n'est pas seulement si je
puis me permettre sur l'aspect social
les sens salariés en CDI mais c'est
aussi l'écosystème les sous-traitants
qu'on faisait travailler etc donc la
responsabilité est lourde donc il y a un
effet d'entraînement quand même de ces
activités industrielles
importantes dans les territoires dans
les dans lesquels dans lesquels nous
sommes implantés
donc le constat sur le reste du groupe
est plutôt favorable d'où ces créations
d'emplois
qui qui sont autant de postes à pouvoir
pour les salariés de Calais
et un environnement effectivement qui
demeure plutôt favorable même si encore
une fois
la localisation encore une fois elle
sera sélective etc est-ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que il faut pas
seulement réfléchir en relocalisation de
ce qui a été délocalisé on serait
incapable de construire de nouvelles
villes de chimie continue des coûts de
l'environnement réglementaire
acceptabilité sociétale etc je crois
nous avons tous conscience donc les
seuls acteurs de la règle localisation
sont les acteurs qui sont déjà en place
avec des possibilités d'investir dans
des capacités qui sont déjà reconnues
pour répondre aux demandes la
relocalisation la plus importante c'est
la relocalisation mentale
c'est celle de l'acheteur dans un
laboratoire pharmaceutique
des acheteurs de laboratoire les
pouvoirs publics les représentants des
pouvoirs publics les élus redécouvrent
la vertu du local et de la proximité
donc c'est c'est et je vais vous étonner
dans mon expérience maintenant depuis 25
ans et particulièrement depuis 2007 avec
accentis j'ai des interlocuteurs
représentant de l'État
qui n'ont pas la même appréciation la
même connaissance et ça c'est une
barrement le
levez demandé une seule façon de dire
toute la vérité y compris celle qui
celle qui me qui me qui me
qu'il fouillé cette expérience je
parlais d'écosystème
vous êtes des élus de collectivités
la façon
d'envisager ces sujets par région par
territoire et différentes vous avez des
cultures du travail qui sont différentes
vous avez des environnements qui sont
plus propices à l'industrie ou pas vous
avez des interlocuteurs des
représentants de l'État
ils sous préfet des préfets change tous
les deux trois ans les lois sont les
mêmes la façon de les appliquer sont
différentes les interlocuteurs que sont
les dréals ou la NSM en fonction
d'inspecteur vous avez pas tout à fait
la même la même acceptation si vous
voulez ou la même connaissance ces
enjeux industriels mais la
désindustrialisation je parle les
dimensions mentales ça a été aussi ça
c'est que vous avez aujourd'hui des
fonctionnaires vous avez des
interlocuteurs qui n'ont plus cette
culture de l'industrie depuis bien
longtemps
et ça c'est une difficulté donc ça a
beaucoup changé
et et quand on parle de relocalisation
c'est encore une fois pour moi surtout
la redécouverte de l'importance de
l'industrie de l'industrie locale et
donc c'est vrai que parmi nous
principaux interlocuteurs aujourd'hui en
matière développement économique
indépendamment de l'État dans le cadre
de France relance vous avez des régions
les régions
est-ce que vous avez vous êtes concerné
par les stocks
puisque vous savez qu'il y a une
obligation de constituer des stocks etc
donc est-ce que vous dans ce cadre là
vous avez des des obligations et quel
est le niveau de vos stocks
alors ça c'est effectivement on parle de
sécurité donc il faut la fois des
capacités disponibles pour répondre à
des variations de demande notamment en
cas de pandémie mais la question encore
une fois qui finance est capacités
disponibles si on veut les les pouvoirs
les mobiliser ça c'est un sujet encore
une fois je permets d'assister
c'est un vrai dilemme économique pour
être compétitif il faut tourner 7 jours
sur 7 vous avez visité l'usine en 58 les
unes sont quasiment tout en 58 ou en 3,8
avec des équipes de week-end tout en
permanence donc
donc sur ces stocks oui nos clients
constituent de plus en plus à nouveau
des stocks de sécurité nous demande de
nous de constituer des stocks de
sécurité de matière première pour
pouvoir transformer les produits la
question quand même il y a dimension
péremption sur dans cette industrie donc
il faut en général avoir des stocks pour
pouvoir garantir
6 9 12 mois de capacité de production
ce que je constate aujourd'hui dans les
relations avec nos clients nos donneurs
d'ordre c'est qui effectivement plus de
volonté
d'aider à constituer à financer des
stocks de sécurité sur les matières
premières voir des intermédiaires voient
même les principes actifs et également à
financer une partie d'investissement
pour il y a donc le rythme de travail
qui peut permettre d'accroître l'offre
mais il y a aussi les investissements
dans quelques capacités complémentaires
ce que l'on fait sur notamment les sites
de grâce ou de Pithiviers
revenir pardon je vais revenir sur votre
histoire de maintien en conditions
industrielle j'ai créé les termes pour
ne pas mettre tromper et en me disant
qu'elle pourrait vous dites en tant que
groupe privé on est allé au bout de ce
qu'on pouvait faire 26 millions c'était
pas possible d'aller aux deux gars
est-ce que quelque part ça aurait été le
rôle de la puissance publique l'État ou
éventuellement la raison de dire les
capacités doivent être maintenues parce
que un jour on pourra produire je ne
sais quelle quel médicament ou en tout
cas que le principe actif est-ce que
vous pensez que ça aurait été
judicieux que la région où l'État
maintiennent cette capacité ne ferme pas
l'entreprise et une ligne principale
donc c'est ça ou 120 personnes qui ont
été licenciées en vue de un éventuel
reprise un projet qui aurait pu vous
avez fait visiter effectivement à des
industriels
qui n'ont pas
qui n'ont pas accrochés qui n'ont pas
trouvé que ça correspondait à leurs
besoins mais est-ce que c'était pas du
rôle de l'État ou de la région se dire
mais un jour on trouvera quelqu'un qui
et on maintient pendant un an deux ans
trois ans ses capacités industrielles et
les fruits qui vont avec
c'est peut-être j'ai livré cette
réflexion très personnelle pour le coup
votre commission
c'est effectivement cette logique de
maintien en condition industrielle qui
existe encore une fois dans les domaines
militaires dans les domaines
stratégiques comme le domaine spatial
etc j'ai connu ça dans une expérience
industrielle précédente
encore voilà il fallut reconnaître le
caractère stratégique des médicaments il
y a bien longtemps etc alors attention
enfin c'est une réflexion très très
personnelle
elle est sans doute assez illusoire aux
garde des doctrines d'intervention de
l'État tel qu'ils ont évolué
il y a des inflexions je parlais de
concurrence déloyale heureusement on
n'est plus dans la même dans le même
droit de la concurrence de l'Union
européenne telle qu'on la concevait il y
a 20 ou 30 ans on commence à protéger un
petit peu on commence à prendre en
compte ce que je disais tout à l'heure
la dévaluation normative ou on évite de
finalement il y a aussi un effet très
pervers
accroissement des normes qui
correspondent à une logique de progrès
que je réfute pas mais qui génère des
surcos pour éviter si surcoût on va
importer
et en important bien on dévalorise en
fait les normes que l'on installe donc
des normes supplémentaires génère des
coûts qui deviennent insupportables en
termes de compétitivité on compte on
s'est compétitivité en important
cette
dimension économique
semble être remise en question
de la Harley jusqu'à considérer que
c'est le rôle d'une région ou de l'état
de d'intervenir très directement sur les
capacités industrielles je crains que on
soit encore une fois très loin de ces de
ces doctrines économiques et
comprendrait bien qu'il ne m'appartient
pas de de mais il me paraissait
important parce que en tout cas je suis
absolument convaincu d'une chose c'est
que l'accès aux médicaments pour le
patient citoyen est aussi important que
d'avoir accès à l'énergie est aussi
important que d'avoir les moyens de
défense
et il existe des outils dans le domaine
énergétique dans le domaine de la
défense dont on pourrait peut-être
s'inspirer mais là je m'en remets
complètement à votre à votre rôle d'élus
il m'appartient pas de de pousser plus
loin cette réflexion
à part donc vous remercier de la
sincérité de vos de vos réponses parce
que
évident
éventuellement on aura peut-être des
questions complémentaires et des
demandes de renseignement complémentaire
si vous pouvez nous les faire parvenir
la démission par
courriel ou par écrit
ce serait ce serait bien merci beaucoup
merci